now you know I'm not scared by any
monsters I don't think I think the only
monster that ever scared me as a kid the
only one as a monster I think was alien
and when I was a kid and and Phantom of
the Opera you know the first of the
lunch anyone not the musical the musical
scares me in a different way
I hate politicians I hate I hate most
everything organized
I hate organized moviemaking and like
institutions I hate big churches
whatever denomination they scare me when
you go to a church and they have their
own giant palace or fortress it is for
me like walking to the dead star you
know I don't care if Darth Vader is
wearing nice robes or not the Los
Angeles police scares the crap out of me
they have this black and white mobile
sharks in the freeway and little there
they are like these machines out of a
horror movie
so III love I like everything to be
Liberty and individual but you know if
you get if you get great individuals you
get a great society so to counter to
counteract the cop cars in LA I am right
now in a project that is very freaky and
personal I'm hand making from scratch
the most brutal car I ever saw which was
in a b-movie I saw as a kid in the 70s
called the car with James Brolin and I
fell in love with that car I I'm making
it expressively to drive in the frequent
looking at the car but I have I have a
hard time I mean I I think that when
people talk about the collapse of
society there's an an anarchist an
anarchist inside me that kind of digs it
you know III I really I'm very afraid of
institutions and especially the ones
that do anything but what they were
supposed to do you know like like
politicians are meant to be there for
the people you know serve the people and
I think that if you really made a scan
of their brain it would be like you know
50% sex 45% power I don't know but it
would be like Oh point zero zero zero
something caring about public
yes it's really it would be a very
discouraging scam